door RAF
hoe wilt u boeren tevreden houden met uw plannen
nou vooral doorzetten
helpen om uit dit systeem
te komen waar ze zelf ook gewoon helemaal
in vast zitten
vooral de veehouderij en de intensieve landbouw
het gif gebruik
we weten nu dat glyfosaat
1 hele grote kans geeft op
dat er 1 relatie is met parkinson
daar zijn boeren natuurlijk het eerste slachtoffer van
als je kijkt naar hoe ze vastzitten in de leningen
bij de rabobank terwijl de veevoerindustrie
in de quote 500 staat dan is er verandering nodig
en het beste wat we kunnen doen is boeren geruststellen
ja er moet veranderd worden
maar we gaan zorgen dat je daar financieel
niet aan onderdoor gaat
en we gaan je helpen in de transitie
dat er veranderd moet worden
dat snap ik en dat is heftig voor boeren
maar als er perspectief is dan geloof ik dat ook boeren
1 gezonde landbouw willen met 1 gezonde bodem
en schoon water
dat doet het huidige systeem helaas niet
maar u zegt dan eigenlijk dat moet het kleinschaliger
ook nou ja vooral
minder dieren
want veehouderij is geen voedselproducent
maar 1 voedselverspiller
en de politiek weet dit wel heel erg lang
en heeft boeren eigenlijk
jarenlang voor de gek gehouden
met doe maar 1 luchtwasser
of 1 andere stalvloer
en dan kan je door met dit systeem
en nu zit de Boer aan alle kanten klem
en dat dat heel heftig voor zich
dat begrijp ik
maar de dieren eruit
dus niet zoveel dieren meer fokker
vetmesten en doden
en overschakelen naar andere vormen van landbouw
dus voedselbossen
plantaardige gewassen telen voor isolatie
voor duurzame bouw
en boeren daar echt
bij helpen dat ze wel Boer kunnen blijven
maar niet meer met zoveel dieren
maar zegt u dan op
D66 heeft ooit bijvoorbeeld
de helft van de veestapel moet eigenlijk weg
wilt u nog verder gaan dan dat
of is licht het niet zo zwart wit met aantallen
ja het ligt zeker wel
zo scherp
en dat is natuurlijk heel verdrietig voor de boeren
dat het dat het zo lang heeft geduurd
maar we moeten minstens 75
minder dieren voor 75
minder dieren fokken en vetmest en slachten
en dat is nodig ook voor klimaat
we hebben binnenkort weer 1 klimaattop
alle wetenschappers zeggen al heel erg lang
we zullen naar veel plantaardiger moeten
dus we moeten zelf ook allemaal minder vlees en zuivel
eten omdat je Anders
klimaatdoelen niet haalt
de natuurcrisis niet oplost
en ook
zorgt het niet voor voedselzekerheid in de toekomst
derk dan
moeten
van u alle boerderijdieren uit de stallen en de natuur
in
veel minder dieren
geeft natuurlijk veel meer ruimte om dieren
weer te kunnen
leven naar hun aard
dus veel minder dieren
geen megastallen meer
en de dieren die nog gehouden worden in de veehouderij
de ruimte geven
varkens moeten kunnen wroeten in de modder
en kippen moeten naar buiten kunnen om te stofbaden
en die hoeven dan niet de natuur in
want de helft van de grond in Nederland
wordt al gebruikt voor de veehouderij
dus daar is ruimte
maar als we omschakelen
dan komt er wel heel veel grond vrij waar we natuur
van kunnen maken
en dan komt er ook eindelijk
ruimte om woningen te bouwen die we nodig hebben
iemand zonder naam
die is de partij voor de dieren
ook voor de mens
bij uitstek
want als je terugdenkt aan bijvoorbeeld Corona
dat is 1 ziekte die oversprong van dier op mensen
zo zijn er heel veel voorbeelden
van de manier waarop we met dieren en natuur omgaan
dat dat voor de mens ook desastreus uitpakt als we
de natuur niet beschermen
de natuur kan prima zonder mensen
maar wij kunnen niet zonder natuur
als we
het water niet beschermen
dan hebben we straks geen schoon drinkwater meer
dus onze plannen beginnen bij
wat is nou belangrijk voor de mens
voor ons voortbestaan
dat gaan we beschermen
en uiteindelijk pakt dat dus voor mensen ook beter uit
maar dat vraagt wel dat we echt de nadruk leggen
op dierennatuur
en klimaat ja
terwijl vroeger eigenlijk altijd de partij
voor de dieren was
ook alleen maar
dierenstandpunten toch eigenlijk heel erg veel
althans de focus lag daarop
is dat dan onder uw leiding toch verschoven
nou het is vooral omdat de partij voor de dieren
is gegroeid kijk in het begin begrijp ik heel goed
dachten mensen wat 1 partij voor de dieren krijgen
1 hond Kat in de
kamer dus dan denken mensen
waar staat die partij voor
en nu we veel langer in de kamer zitten
en ook zijn gegroeid
zien mensen
ook onze andere standpunten veel duidelijker
dus dat we ook
strijden tegen de armoede in Nederland
en dat we strijden tegen de bezuinigingen
in de verpleeghuiszorg
en dat zagen mensen
natuurlijk in de eerste paar jaren niet
toen dachten nou het gaat alleen maar over dieren
maar we zijn altijd veel breder geweest
maar we houden altijd de nadruk op het belang
van het beschermen van onze leefomgeving
en dus dier en natuur en milieu
omdat als je dat niet doet
dan is er geen bestaanszekerheid voor niemand